[Música]
con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar de Los costos del mundial
de Qatar tanto de cuánto dinero se tuvo
que invertir en infraestructura hasta el
que ASUME los aficionados durante su
estadía en una ciudad comodoja donde el
lujo y la opulencia elevan por supuesto
Los costos de vida incluso algunos
tildan este evento como el mundial de
los millonarios saludamos entonces a
Jorge Hernán peleas él es columnista del
diario La República y director de ala
Paredón gracias a Jorge por estar con
nosotros en directo América de Francia
24 y también nos acompaña en el estudio
nuestro cronista de deportes Rodrigo
sedano buenas es un tema muy interesante
este del costo en el mundial desde luego
Jorge yo quisiera empezar preguntándoles
si realmente Este es el mundial de los
millonarios Como algunos lo dicen porque
solamente hablamos de Los tiquetes para
ir hasta dos a sobre todo el continente
americano y la estadía y ya estamos
hablando de una gran cantidad de dinero
que por supuesto No el grueso de la
población se puede costar
Raúl y Rodrigo Muchas gracias por
invitarme a esta transmisión de Franz 24
en español activos de beber estoy a la
salida de uno de los estadios que tienen
algún paneo hacia allá al fondo detrás
de los semáforos se ve el estadio al
yarubí acabo de estar en el partido
entre Camerún y Serbia 33 gran juego y
Bueno la verdad Estuve Caminando por la
zona conociendo un poco y como pueden
darse cuenta ya está cerquita de caer el
sol en la tarde de hoy acá en dos
azuladas 4-15 minutos y una temperatura
de más o menos 24 grados centígrados
usted tiene razón Este es el Mundial de
la gente con plata en el mundo lo que yo
he podido ver en los estadios en las
tribunas es gente de África de Europa de
Norteamérica de Japón pero gente de unos
estratos muy altos con relojes lujosos
las mujeres con carteras de miles de
dólares muy bien vestidas
eso al menos en las tribunas es lo que
se ve de los estadios donde se han
desarrollado los partidos más
importantes de esta primera fase de la
gente local los catalíes también Pues
dicen que los que han podido comprar las
entradas no son baratas hay entradas de
catalíes que en Morelia local si lo
convertimos a Colombia Son 350 mil pesos
aproximadamente estamos hablando de un
poco menos de 90 dólares las entradas
más baratas pero si usted busca por
ejemplo entrada para la final que
todavía no se sabe y va a estar Brasil o
Argentina o Francia ahí boletas de 2000
dólares tres mil dólares dependiendo La
Tribuna el alojamiento para que se den
una idea no se consigue ninguna
alojamiento de menos de 100 dólares en
la noche en los hoteles de tres
estrellas no muy lujosos obviamente los
de cuatro o cinco estrellas el tema
supera los 400 dólares por noche y
ustedes mostraron al principio unos
contenedores ahí se alojaban la gente
que también tenía posibilidad de venir
de pronto en un plan menos formal como
decimos en Colombia mochilero esos
contenedores fueron adecuados para
habitaciones de personas y también unos
cruceros a la salida en el mar donde la
gente duerme del crucero y durante el
día de los estadios yo le hago un
cálculo rápido para para allá que
ustedes sigan con la pregunta cualquier
colombiano que se venga a estarse todo
el mes del mundial no baja el gasto de
30 millones de pesos por persona es más
o menos lo que cuesta desde Colombia
venir al mundial yo me imagino que en
otras partes del mundo es un precio
similar
30 millones de pesos colombianos que
desde luego no se lo puede permitir todo
el mundo y nos estaba hablando usted de
hemos hecho referencia también a
contenedores incluso una especie de
cajas de cartón que se han ido
acomodando para que lleguen los
aficionados ha habido críticas incluso
porque parece que se están construyendo
sobre la marcha según llega la gente
según la capacidad que tiene Qatar para
albergar este mundial se queda corta por
la cantidad de aficionados que llegan
pero le quería preguntar también por
cómo se ve la asistencia de los países
de África en concreto de los del norte
de África que se ha denominado a este
mundial como el primero en el mundo
árabe sí que ha habido una mayor
asistencia quizás con respecto a otros
mundiales de aficionados llegados de
estos países un poco más cercanos pero a
los que también les cuesta desde luego
una gran suma de dinero llegar hasta
allá o como nos indicaba simplemente se
ven gente de estratos muy altos
tiene usted razón ha venido mucha gente
del África del Norte
digamos que he tenido la posibilidad de
estar como hoy el partido de Camerún
mucha gente de Camerún tuve la
posibilidad de ver el primer partido de
túnez también mucha gente de Tunes Yo
diría que un 80% del Estado de Veracruz
ese día lo mismo
otros países que han estado como
Marruecos que ayer sorpresivamente le
ganó a Bélgica Y decía hay digamos una
presencia alta porque para hacerle
rápido el análisis Rodrigo Por ejemplo
si usted se viene desde Europa cualquier
ciudad Madrid Frankfurt Roma
Estambul que es como los destinos más
comunes hasta doja puede conseguir
tiquetes aéreos en Qatar airway de 600
800 dólares dependiendo de la hora del
día y de cuántas paradas desde África
hay gente que se ha venido con unas
aerolíneas africanas por menos de 300
dólares es la mitad de precio para los
que de África vía aérea y hay otra
fórmula para la gente que por ejemplo
los argentinos que ayer estuvieron en
victoria hay mucho argentino que no se
está quedando en dos rescatar se quedan
en Dubai o se quedan en Arabia Saudita y
solo vienen a los partidos de Argentina
de primera ronda y el día del partido
vienen en avión y vuelven y se van en
avión para no pagar hoteles les sale más
barato pagar el hotel en países de al
lado como Arabia Saudita o irse hasta
Dubai a hoteles de pronto de las mismas
estrellas pero más barato porque ellos
no tienen el mundial y pagar el tiquete
aéreo que desde Arabia Sí es muy es muy
barato ahí tiquetes aéreos de menos de
100 dólares ahorita para cazar con
muchas frecuencias diarias en diferentes
aerolíneas
también Jorge hablemos de algo muy
importante y es de estos trabajadores
que construyeron los trabajadores
migrantes que construyeron todos los
estadios para este mundial Ellos dicen
que no han sido tratados después de la
mejor manera incluso que ni siquiera han
tenido la cortesía de Y darles entradas
como para entrar a ver en cualquier
partido sino que los tienen como que en
una especie de fans son o para poder ver
los partidos esto se ve en las calles de
doja realmente esta situación con los
migrantes o es más de lo que relata la
prensa internacional
digamos que el tema de los migrantes se
dio antes del mundial antes de comenzar
Sí fue como a las carreras porque al
igual que Brasil 2014 algunos estaban
ellos se terminaban de construir una
semana antes del comienzo del Campeonato
Aquí también tuvieron afanes sobre todo
en las zonas que les tocó adecuar cuando
se dieron cuenta que los estadios
necesitaban espacio para las personas
con discapacidad sitios para que las
mamás guarden los coches de sus bebés
lockers para la gente que puede de
pronto guardar ahí objetos que no puede
ingresar al estadio entonces toda la
logística alrededor de los estadios fue
lo último en hacerse y si lo terminaron
hace muy pocos días La verdad la verdad
si la prensa internacional ha estado muy
encima del tema de los trabajadores que
muchos vienen de Asia de países como
Pakistán de Malasia de África también
Vienen A trabajadores y ellos denuncian
que se ganan o se ganaban
unas tarifas diarias realmente muy bajas
50 de la moneda local catarí que podrían
ser unos 60 mil pesos colombianos por
trabajos de 12 a 15 horas y sin descanso
sin permiso para ir al baño muy estricta
la la jornada en la construcción de los
estadios porque tenían una fecha límite
y tenía que cumplirla Y al igual que en
el mundial de Brasil
se empezaron a trazar las obras Pues
porque hay días de demasiado calor donde
los trabajadores no soportan las
jornadas es cierto lo que dicen los
medios internacionales de que ha habido
maltrato pero ahí viene la duda
razonable es de los constructores con
contratados es del Gobierno local es de
la misma FIFA ahí sí entraría una
investigación que nos tomaría mucho
tiempo pero los constructores cumplieron
con la FIFA al menos con los tiempos
establecidos y ellos tuvieron que
asumirlos sobre costos y todo el tema
laboral que supone haber traído personas
de otros países y Jorge Una última
pregunta quería hacerle por su
experiencia personal y la de sus colegas
nuestros colegas periodistas allá como
está siendo el trato con respecto
también a lo que Comenta de los propios
trabajadores ha habido problemas hubo
problemas al inicio del mundial también
están siendo bien tratados por la
policía catari
bueno bueno le voy a contar mi caso
personal para que una idea Rodrigo de
comas ha sido esa experiencia
me he encontrado en la realidad en la
calle los estadios en los centros
comerciales las estaciones de metro con
una población mayoritariamente bilingüe
muy decentes muy respetuosos y sobre
todo muy organizados y muy ordenados
ellos lo que pasa es que si se
encargaron de llenar de logística y de
policía todos los sitios de presencia
masiva y hay muy pocas posibilidades de
equivocarse en cada punto de encuentro
donde hay personal de logística hay
personal que habla inglés francés
español varios idiomas también de Asia y
de África Entonces los turistas y las
personas que van de la prensa digamos no
tiene como perderse es muy fácil todo a
la entrada del aeropuerto a todo turista
que tenía boleta le regalaron una SIM
Card con dos gigas de datos gratis para
que se pudiera comunicar el primer día
con su familia y ya después de ir
adelante las personas recargan la SIM
cards pues Dependiendo los planes de
datos que cada uno quiera
sorprendentemente las pocas personas con
las que he podido hablar largos minutos
y largo tiempo
cuando me hablan de Colombia me hablan
de Maluma me hablan de J Balvin digamos
que el mundial es anteriores a uno le
hablaban de James Falcao Shakira Carlos
Vives pero ahora los colombianos que
están sonando en estas partes del mundo
son esos dos reguetoneros que por
supuesto son muy taquilleros Y de alguna
manera estuvieron invitados a la
inauguración y Maluma cantó Y pues esa
es nuestra cara ahora sí Maluma es un
taquillero no solo en Colombia sino en
el mundo y esa es la forma como ellos
nos ven a nosotros